je voudrais évidemment revenir
sur un sujet que vous connaissez
donc vous avez été informé et et qu'a
notamment cité votre directeur de
cabinet qui est un point important qui
est finalement la suppression d'une
subvention à une association qui est
depuis a été cité par la presse elle
n'avait pas été un audition mais c'est
SOS Racisme
et simplement vous dire qu'il
y a là-dessus plusieurs aspects qui sont
étonnants et quelquefois un peu choquant
le premier c'est que
le 25 mai a lieu le comité de sélection
le 25 mai et le 27 mai il y a un mail de
votre membre de votre cabinet
au préfet Gravel en disant j'ai soumis à
la ministre votre note on fait le point
demain
votre note c'est à dire la note
concernant le comité de sélection de la
veille
ou deux jours avant et juste après vous
prenez il y a une décision qui est prise
par vous selon votre directeur de
cabinet qui est de supprimer une ligne
budgétaire du comité de sélection qui
est celle concernant SOS Racisme je
crois que ça a autant de cent mille
euros de mémoire
et qui était elle dans le comité de
sélection donc si vous voulez on a parlé
des problématiques avant le comité de
sélection on a parlé des problématiques
durant le comité de sélection et même
après le comité de sélection comme il y
a toujours pas de compte-rendu du comité
de sélection
en réalité le comité de sélection
je ne sais pas si sélectionne on sait
plus puisque à la sortie comme vous
dites vous validez mais en fait quand
vous validez le résultat du comité de
sélection en réalité vous influez sur le
résultat vous influencer le résultat en
supprimant et et votre directeur de
cabinet a une expression particulière en
indiquant que c'est suite d'ailleurs à
des questions personnelles entre
l'expression et pas exactement celle là
mais l'esprit c'est cela
passé entre vous et l'association en
question est-ce que vous pouvez nous
dire
comment les choses se passent dans cette
affaire là si Monsieur le Directeur de
Cabinet Monsieur le Préfet a eu
raison de présenter les choses ainsi
est-ce que vous dites non c'est pas le
cas enfin qu'est-ce que vous répondez à
ça
bien sûr monsieur le Président je vous
remercie de me poser la question et me
permettre justement d'apporter des
éléments de d'éclairage je répondrai à
tous les points sans exception d'abord
je vais être très clair je n'ai pas
supprimé de subventions à SOS Racisme je
dis pas que c'est ce que vous avez dit
mais j'ai vu des réponses qui ont été
portées en ce sens disant que mes
décisions auraient mis en péril un
équilibre financier d'une association je
rappelle qu'on est sur un appel à projet
on parle pas de financement ni de
fonctionnement pour les associations
donc je n'enlève pas de l'argent à SOS
racisme dont il bénéficierait chaque
année
alors je vais je vais y revenir mais en
tout cas première élément
c'est subtil comme réponse je pense que
le droit emporte monsieur le Président
d'une part et d'autre part au-delà du
droit quand la réalité est aussi là
c'est à dire vous n'attribuez pas 100000
€ qui avait été sélectionné n'est pas la
même chose que supprimer
je vais vous répondre en essayant d'être
le plus factuel possible dans la mesure
où à titre personnel je n'avais aucun
souvenir du fait qu'il y ait eu des
discussions sur SOS Racisme dans le
cadre du fond Marianne
maintenant qu'on a appelé ce sujet à mon
attention j'ai souvenir qu'il y ait eu
des échanges sur SOS Racisme je me base
sur les faits et sur les échanges écrits
que j'ai pu trouver pour rétablir une
chronologie
ce qu'on me ce que je comprends
aujourd'hui ce qu'on me dit c'est qu'il
y a une liste établie par le comité de
sélection du fond Marianne avec des
dossiers qui font l'unanimité du comité
de sélection et avec certains qui sont
entre guillemets en liste complémentaire
c'est-à-dire pour débat je comprends de
ce qu'on me dit aujourd'hui que SOS
Racisme fait partie de cette liste
complémentaire et qu'il n'y a pas
consensus au sein du comité de sélection
et qu'il y a divergences certains
considérants qui ne faut pas attribuer
cette subvention et d'autres considérant
contraire qu'il faut attribuer cette
subvention le point mais m'excusant
c'est pas le compte enfin c'est pas le
compte rendu que nous avons du préfet le
préfet nous dit j'ai simplement demandé
qu'il y ait une réserve sur ce dossier
pour pouvoir vous en parler
personnellement c'est pas la même chose
que de dire qu'il y a un désaccord il y
a pas de désaccord il y a simplement
une précaution de vérification auprès de
vous d'un accord sur le fait qu'on voilà
je comprends bien que ce n'est pas la
même chose Monsieur le Président mais
moi c'est la version que j'ai
aujourd'hui et que je partage avec vous
aujourd'hui d'après ce qu'on me dit
d'après ce que je retrouve dans les
échanges ce qu'on vous dit Madame c'est
ce que vous savez quand même vous
oubliez pas tout de votre vie quand même
je veux dire monsieur le Président mais
en deux ans j'ai eu à présider un
certain nombre de réunions à rendre un
certain nombre d'arbitrages et surtout
je ne peux pas me souvenir de réunion
auquel je n'ai pas participé